I'm excited about this one rob henry you
have played the Tutan fall titanfall 2
yeah and Sam Pelaez yeah crazy mech
creation at peter brown you did the
second take review of titanfall yes sir
first what did you give it a second take
a view in eight days yeah that was a fun
game I yeah it was like it made me not
have the buyer's remorse about the xbox
one for a while there and I was like
real solid gang to plan that it's a lot
of it on 360 oh you did after the raid
are you oh yeah cuz I didn't have an
xbox one and another one it felt like
one of those first like you know I think
we talked about it at the time that like
gears of war game the one were like
everyone was rallied around just one
game everyone online like he went your
friends on xbox one and it was just like
titanfall time for time for and a weird
things kind of happen since we're the
movement mechanics that they were sort
of showing off in that game have
basically been adopted by call of duty
and you could say we're so used to
living games like overwatch now and even
battle born and I guess the new owner
tournament as well at Rob you guys put
out a really good feature last week
about the single-player this new one
today about the multiplayer that's right
you've played it that's a fan what do
you think of titanfall 2 is it
interesting to you or does it feel like
another you know let's is it a shallow
sequel or is it actually doing something
interesting it's it's really cool to see
where they've gone since the first game
and I think they have filled in a lot of
the missing elements from the first game
with this may it be like a easier way to
like find servers with like a new net
networking feature that actually known
what has really talked about too much
but basically it's like a nice way of
like lobbies and you know developing
groups that you're familiar with into
getting into games quicker and easier
with familiar players it was definitely
a problem especially the morality after
the game came out yeah I'm eventually
was playing by myself and then the
progression system is what we're thought
out this time around no burn cards aslam
know Brooks o'byrne cards have taken an
interesting tool so basically yet I mean
you know a lot of the features or the
features that we would have been working
on today it's there is definitely a
swing away from the modern shooter which
would which could be said to be like
Call of Duty like everyone can do
everything right now its heroes more
roast shooters with classes classes with
abilities and that's where this game is
going and that's what's actually really
exciting for me was because you get a
very strong character when you get these
Titans now opposed to like customizing
your Titan let your loadout now these
Titans are specific and you know what
you're getting into so on the field if I
see X Titan I know what he's capable of
I know what is all tis I know what his
moves is is he a close range as you as
you're a distant Titan well what's his
you know and they had an element of that
in the last game where there was like
the the the one that was like slower and
bigger and there was like the speedy one
is all around around right but the move
sets weren't different but like that now
they have like straight of oats and
stuff like that Oh totally yeah so one
Titans got like a fat laser beam which
was so awesome to use like yeah I mean
you you see it a Titan you know is
capable of and that goes as far as his
weapons as well I think I mean correct
me if I'm wrong prior Titans you could
pick your own weapon so you weren't
necessarily sure what weapon he had what
I got honest i can t remember worth our
t-shirt different classes for the actual
pilots is Wireless summer enemy yes so
pilots also have more or less an
ultimate as well those they did have
different loads last time as well yes
and this time around it and that's kind
of where the burn cards have kind of
shifted into is like this ultimate so
it's a ticker just like how you know
typical overwatch games work that lead
up to a you know your customizable alt
abilities so may it be amped weapon so
remember burn cards would have amped SMG
yes I'm like that that's kind of where
it fits in okay there's also the other
only other one they showed were these
kind of remote mind ticks that you know
you throw down and you could kind of
guarantee that there they'll find a
target and explode on them yeah there's
a lot of cool changes I would say that
it's very much yeah like class and
character shifting like you know like
you you see even a player like actually
now your your players abilities may be a
cloak a hologram as of now those are
visually applied to each pilot and so
like I can see now a
a a character that looks like the cloak
character with texture and skin and I
know that that's weeks capable so where
they're like what how does that manifest
in terms of how you're playing the game
because you know a lot of times are you
playing you know the classes in
different games you don't care just
gonna shoot the man face anyway you know
the extremity of that would be something
like overwatch we're like oh I am this
person and I'm going into this person I
need to kill them this way when you're
fighting the titans are there like
certain Titans which shouldn't go up
against other Titans are certain Titans
that you should only attack like a
certain way like yeah I was a
manifesting in the battles yeah I mean
we only got to see two of the titans
they've mentioned this Ronin type which
is a the sword wheeling Titan who is
supposedly very much close quarters
right um but you take for instance the
scorcher Titan he has a very much an AoE
type of attack so he like will throw
down flames that will completely cover
the ground so if you're gonna be
attacking him as even as a pilot rush
get off the ground get on the building
and intact above ion is the other
tighten with the red laser like he's
very much a long distance i would say
type of guy who's throwing mines i mean
there's yeah you are recognizing a Titan
in you're behaving differently and any
difference in the sort of the the park
Rory elements to it I mean there was
kind of first at the gate with that
stuff and network all used to double
jumped and running on walls and all that
just well actually bring Christopher
stay put that but I I'd say the speed is
a little slow down okay that's not I was
on what just feels that way it felt like
actually there was even more of a push
to get momentum and which would generate
more speed by doing parkour moves and
then what I just had the best time with
is this new grapple and I was really
curious to know how this fit in because
from the e3 trailer it was like oh
really just tacking on a grapple hook
right it feels so good better than any
almost any grapple I've ever listen to
like it's not just Widowmaker it's not
like you it's not just like a teleport
button that it is in that game it's more
or like in quake I guess this is more of
like there's it's got like bionic
commando or something right you're using
it's like arc you can like swing
sideways and stuff with it right and you
can even
or give slack oh cool very cutting up
but the biggest thing I found is you
know you tighten it up yeah you heard me
big as we know titanfall from the first
game there are there aren't necessarily
Lane license fall titanfall there are
there are just obstacles around you and
you create your own lanes right for as
far as parkour so many times there were
things were cool that's pretty far away
well there's where my grapple is I can
attach to a building and swing further
and get to that wall that's further
along and that was really cool was being
able to have a different mindset and and
mine step in like fill in the gaps but
yeah that's kind of interesting people
are totally gonna break the levels in
this game that's what I want to know
about is the levels i guess like what
are the map designs like an
aesthetically do they stand out from the
first game because I'm while you're
talking and walking watching footage
behind you and I'm seeing very familiar
settings here for the most part maybe
trees look new all right so had a lot of
this I've seen before I would agree I
this is it's not to me a friend man I'm
that's fine because I never had a
problem with no I don't know either I'm
just curious if there's anything we're
not seeing here because I would love to
be surprised with some pretty you know
outlandish environments I think this
game mode we're looking at right now
actually is something to be worth noted
is it's called bounty hunt hmm and
essentially it was actually surprisingly
really fun it's kind of got like a war
zone feel to it from Halo okay we're
like there are these events to enemy
Titans that are NPCs will come down and
you attack those you rake up money on
school and then the thing is is you then
have to a certain points in the match to
get out of your Titan and cash in all
right okay so it is forcing people to
get out of titans allowed in the bank
right which is great because you're now
you're vulnerable right because you get
this empowerment in a Titan and I would
say there's nothing better than getting
into a Titan getting out of Titan like
feeling unsafe but knowing you being
chased by someone and running out after
cashing in and like ziplining into your
tight and it's being like now what like
let's go like it creates a cool dynamic
that was what was very strong because
that's just you know and that's what
they're really milking is like your
Titan and pilot connection yes actually
let's get into
the single-player stuff did you play
some of this I just saw a demo I think
most people have seen some of the clips
of it but yeah that was pretty great
weird your your tightness kind of
sentient you guys are having
conversations like you're literally like
choosing between one or two you know to
dialogue options yeah you know these I
guess yeah and how did that stuff sort
of look to you I mean the thing that I'm
a [ __ ] about this is that like obviously
been some fellow Jason West were the
masterminds behind were caught a call of
duty the whole way up to I guess I
coffers the last from probably modern
warfare maybe no maybe the one after
that maybe like black ops maybe was the
last one I forget but like some of the
best thing of very narratives in like
what we would consider you know
mainstream shooters and this is then
doing that for the first world sorry
it's I'm pehle doing it for the first
time and with respawn how did it look to
you dude you know one of the things they
did really good was not just have they
weren't just boring like they had
interesting set pieces made interesting
you know individual link scenarios and
takes had it headed a look that it looks
just like then the nose shooting or was
it more interesting than it looked
pretty great and it's definitely a
single-player component like 10 percent
what we you know we talked to those got
the guys devs and they mentioned um kind
of like this interesting ratio which is
you know as they were developed a single
player they kind of broke it down to
like okay what are you actually doing
with a type one being tight in combat
one being pilot combat and then one
being kind of the park or nature of your
pilot right so he said that's kind of
what the ratio is which is like it's
like two parts pilot combat one part
time in combat in one part parkour so
those interchange throughout the kind of
layout of the entire campaign right so
you know you start off really and no no
swell this is kind of what happens is is
you your Titan BTW is down and he need
batteries so the first part is okay well
he goes you need to go find batteries
I've scanned across the map this
open-world kind of ask ya setting go
find any batteries so now you're using
your piden you're hiding your tie pilot
skills to parkour around and write fine
batteries it looked a bit like something
like dying light or something or yeah
totally like running along walls I guess
I'm like platforming yeah you know
first-person style and now and that look
really great so yeah you know you're
going into camps and you're using cloak
you know you cool very it's very open
world esque and then they showed us
another part where it's you know you're
inside and you're kind of forced to get
out of your Titan in order to you know
basically find your way and have kind
like a platforming puzzle aspect in
order to get your Titan through right
you know you can imagine all these
different elements like like papaya or
something or overtime or Agra d you know
even like the comparisons of like
half-life 2 you know I would dog but
there's literally yet dog or there's
even like a fricking like kind of
grabbing in that gravity gun there's a
gun you get to like open up platforms
right okay and anyway even there to even
showed us things where you get into like
a crane and you move a wall around in
order to then parkour down right um so
it just goes back and forth like that
you know sometimes you can't have your
Titan sometimes you can that's
interesting it's like it's almost like
they're doing with the one thing to call
of duty never did which was you know for
all the wonderful things that did in
those campaigns were very like Lane they
were very like blinkers were on you're
going down this hallway go do it as
opposed to like the you know some of the
best first-person shooters of all time
like you talked about how flight which
do go okay here's a set-piece figure it
out yeah you're a big fan of it Peter
what do you think about time fall to
sort of looking at rob's features and
some of the gameplay we've seen today
I'm super excited I mean the first game
had a wonderful foundation that I just
felt needed to be expanded upon and this
game appears to be doing that and
honestly that's exactly how I feel yeah
as long as it gives me what I had before
and then some I'm in are you self Rob
you've seen it in action you've played
the multiplayer more or less interested
now actually after coming back from from
playing it it's just it's super fun I
mean I feel like I just kind of rambled
the whole time just now it's like
there's so much to actually be said I
think they've they've they've taken a
lot of things from the first game I
think that that we're missing like a lot
of teamwork elements like i mentioned
kind of like the the network and
lobbying that kind of wasn't really
present there's a lot more team
qualities that are implemented into the
gameplay mechanics for instance I think
one a huge one which I don't you caught
this in the future I did is no longer
you know
you could rodeo a enemy Titan and shoot
his like we are again not anymore it's
one that you can basically already have
to do is you have to remove a battery
okay from his from his top which
eliminates half his health your your
force her house they got email tone
thank you you're forced off the Titan I
can either get back on that Titan throw
a grenade and that that empty slot yeah
that'll do it the other part that is
awesome is I'd now have a battery I can
go up to a friendly Titan and shove the
battery in him boosting his shield and
giving half his health oh wow that's
awesome awesome so literally I have this
gameplay footage where I'm as a
spectacle I'm seeing you know two titans
of my friendly Titan in anytime anytime
going at it I swing in I do just that I
get on the back I find a good moment I
rip out the battery and then I swing
back and I go to my buddy and put it in
and end up like you're like a medic yeah
I end up like boosting his like a shield
and he actually ends up winning in the
fight like it was freakin awesome so
it's you know you had these almonds like
rodeoing you know other friendly titans
like there's this these elements of team
play that um I really got a kick out of
like there's there's nothing more like
fun to like help out some like that
that's awesome yeah last question what
did you play on that was ps4 okay
interesting so that's even better right
like now PlayStation players can
experience 10 phone yeah yes for Xbox
one and PC sorry pc folks but the xbox
one and ps4 people are getting a
technical test for the remaining
weekends in august are you laughing it's
a beta no it's a technical a single
either way ever heard of technical
because now the word Veda implies a game
oh yeah it's all [ __ ] they should just
called enough oh no and yes there is a
beta basically coming out apparently
it's open this weekend starting August
nineteenth and it will also be on the
following weekend as well so if you're
interested you do not have very long to
wait